thanksgiving night on nbc mike tarico
and chris collinsworth on the call it
will be steelers ravens even though the
ravens continue chris to get more
positive results yesterday linebacker
pernell mcphee joined the list of
players who have tested positive and
will not play running backs mark ingram
j.k dobbins already out for thursday's
game brandon williams on covet 19
reserve could possibly emerge from it
but if he was exposed on sunday
the math doesn't work it doesn't allow
him
to get off of that list until friday
because you got a five-day absence if
you had close contact with someone who
was positive but you know what here's
the thing doesn't matter doesn't matter
because the nfl's attitude became with
that buccaneers raiders game several
weeks ago we're playing next man up you
don't have a guy get a guy practice
squad wherever however
suit him up and let's go and i think
that's going to continue to be the nfl's
attitude unless
there are
ultimately
insufficient raw numbers of guys who can
be put on the field at any given time
yeah well i mean you know in a lot of
ways i like that that you know the nfl
is not going to back down or change or
try to reschedule or do things like that
you know and appeal to teams who yeah
have lost the battle for the time being
to cover die team i i'm all for that you
know to me that keeps the incentive of
what we talked about all off season
where hey you know it's on the players
to oh man we're in the middle of a legit
playoff race and if we lose one more
game we might be out of here maybe i
shouldn't go to a restaurant or go to
some gathering or something like that
and i understand you can't avoid the
virus at all costs i get that i'm not
trying to be incent insensitive that way
but you know i i think that you know the
incentive here
is pretty apparent and as for a team
like the baltimore ravens you know it's
unfortunate that's hit them right now
and basically we're getting down into
like must-win territory and a huge game
for them not you know forget the
division to go to the playoffs so that's
where
that's where you know i like the stance
of the nfl in this matter right now
because ultimately comes back to hurt
the team that
you know deserves to get hurt for for
for lack of a better way to say that
and and let me
amplify one of your points because i
will be insensitive because i don't
think it is insensitive to say that nfl
players should be avoiding the virus at
all costs they have the resources they
have the means i know set up in their
homes a place where they go now hey
you're home with your family but that
doesn't mean you have to be face to face
with them especially if they're possibly
being exposed to people who have it you
have a room that you go to you take all
the precautions wash your hands wash
your hands and don't breathe the same
air as the other people who are living
in the house who possibly have been
infected it's not that difficult if
you're committed to it and it's stay
home it's don't go out it's treat this
thing as a five month challenge to stay
away from the virus and keep the virus
away from you if you truly want to avoid
hurting yourself i know you're right the
the alternative is stay in a hotel yeah
that's the thing the nfl has tried to
balance this so guys can go home
but if you catch it
you're out period you still get paid
right it's not like the game's canceled
and you lose your game check but you
you're you're contributing to the parade
of guys who potentially could result in
the whole thing collapsing so yeah
there's a level of personal
responsibility here and i don't think
there's anything wrong with saying so
you're right i just meant you know like
it's hard sometimes especially if the
kid you know your kid is going to school
doing things like that but you're right
i mean there's there's still plenty of
ways to avoid it i just wasn't trying to
sound like a total jerk good job doing
it for me i'll go ahead and be the chair
i'll go ahead and be a total jerk
because because you're you're right
you want to be able to play yeah
that's the ultimate thing here do you
think here as we get into now thanks
post thanksgiving
you know if i'm teams towards the bottom
of the playoff shuffle right now and i'm
a coach
man i i would i'd have a hard time not
starting to say stuff to my players and
my coaches here if we're going down like
hey if you're the raiders who are or
maybe the raiders aren't a good example
because they're practicing herd immunity
there uh but if you're the arizona
cardinals or tampa bay down here in the
stretch these type of teams where you
know like hey we're in the bottom of the
playoff picture right now one or two
more losses we could be in trouble and
be out of this thing i don't know do
these organizations continue to you know
try to push players to do that and go
into the hotel i mean i'm i'm fascinated
by that aspect of it i mean because
legacies are on the line here for
players for teams for coaches a lot of
them i mean i think of adam thielen hey
adam thielen could be nfl touchdowns
receiving leader this year now he's got
coven he might never be able to hold
that you know title again so there's a
lot here and you know i i that's where i
just wonder if if this will come up now
the thanksgiving's over and we're gonna
end december and it's that last push i
don't know you got any thoughts there
well theon has coveted unless he doesn't
there is a report that he was positive
and now he's negative oh yeah who ended
up being negative but you know what i
mean by the example i know but i know
what you mean look i i just wanted to
make sure we didn't give anybody the
wrong impression and the thing it's
impossible to keep up with everything as
it relates to covert on top of following
the games
we have this separate universe of news
that has infiltrated football this year
and hopefully it'll be for this year
only
i know that the league has been
petrified of what may happen when teams
are no longer as a practical matter in
the hunt will the players still be
vigilant and i talked to kyle rudolph
about that back when the vikings were
one in five i said what's what do you do
as a veteran to get the message across
he said it's not difficult guys no if we
don't play we don't get paid so if all
of a sudden we throw caution to the wind
and half the team has covid like we see
with these college programs where they
don't have a financial incentive you
know people say well why are all these
college games being cancelled the kids
don't have any financial incentive to
not get it and they don't care they're
impervious to it or at least they
believe they are until they're not but
the vast majority of them don't get
seriously ill so that's why we see games
getting canceled every week and i think
that as we do get deeper into the season
it is a real concern the teams that are
contenders i think will be locked down
even harder and maybe you do see teams
in a hotel voluntarily where the leaders
of the team the player leaders are the
ones who say we're all staying in the
hotel sorry that's just what we're going
to do
but it really is a concern and chris my
big concern is we had the admonition
last week from the cdc don't travel
the travel numbers through the roof yeah
through the roof only people were
traveling people than last year
yeah they're going to gather
they're going to they're going to
share the same air they're going to not
be as careful as they could be or should
be because it's a holiday everything is
different on a holiday nothing counts on
a holiday until the day after the
holiday when you realize it the scale
still says what it says based on how
much i ate and i may get sick because of
who i was standing next to all day long
who came in from new york city and flew
through two different airports to get
here that's
the problem because all those infections
as the numbers keep going up and up
that's just more opportunities for the
players and the coaches when they go
home when they leave the facility to end
up getting it and and that's where we're
going to be in a few
weeks i think jennifer has to be very
nervous very nervous about next week the
week after into december very very
nervous about where this is going to go
i agreed um because i've had this
through text with with a coach friend of
mine too who's talked about like you
know they try to give the message to the
team
to limit thanksgiving you know
very close family things like that but i
think you know there's a thought out
there with coaches like you're just not
going to tell some of these men
to not have you know more of their
extended family over there and i know
that's careless and it's you know
irresponsible but you know at the same
time
it's a weird time right now people are
locked down they want to be with their
family and i'm not trying to make any
excuses i'm making an excuse here but i
think that's inside some of the the
logic of what players and people are
thinking through the holidays and man i
mean next week i just that's where i
keep thinking about
yeah you know my uncle johnny came in
from kentucky and you know my aunt
jeannie came in from florida blah blah
blah blah blah and they were here and
now you know i'm back in the locker room
and hey your family had who there oh
this guy from alabama and this guy from
california oh great i mean so that it's
just it seems like it's a recipe for
disaster uh going into next week
and i agree with you chris and i i
revert back to
good old-fashioned leadership
what is leadership
if it isn't telling people things they
don't want to hear and expecting them to
do things they don't want to do or to
not do things they want to do we all
need a little bit of that at times left
our own devices we will make bad
decisions from time to time because
we'll make selfish or stupid decisions
and we all need someone who can tell us
when we're about to do something that is
not the smartest thing we could do
there's nothing wrong with that so i
don't think a coach is being a jerk by
sending the message to his players hey
guys i know it's thanksgiving but you
know what you can get a damn turkey
anytime get your turkey in january after
the season's over have thanksgiving then
all it is is a bunch of food you don't
need to risk your interest our interests
your money our money because you're
getting together with a bunch of people
from out of town and you aren't able to
say no to them you tell them your coach
said no you tell them your coach said
this is what you have to do and you know
for the teams playing on thanksgiving it
gives them a little bit of an out maybe
it's a great thing this year to be one
of the six teams playing thanksgiving
but but i i just i i look uh and and
here's why here's why i'm i'm you start
you get a little irritated because i
know what's gonna happen we've spent 15
minutes talking about this now my email
box is going to be full of complaints
from all the people out there who never
wanted to take this seriously who still
refuse to take this seriously and don't
want to hear us talking about it and my
message to them is look folks if you
insert expletives
five or six of them had taken this
seriously back in march we wouldn't be
screwing around with this right now so
don't blame us because it's news in the
nfl because it's a legitimate concern as
to whether or not we're going to get the
season and it's your fault because you
didn't take it seriously when the rest
of us did that we're still in this mess
so don't complain if we have to talk
about it now because it's still going on
now because you didn't take it seriously
that's the kind of message that needs to
be sent if we're ever going to get this
thing fixed yeah no well you're right
you're right now you know those people
you're talking to too though you know it
goes back to something you said earlier
leadership and that never happened in
our country we never had a national
response
yeah that's gonna happen soon so well
yeah hopefully it happens soon people
are confused people don't know what the
how how you know i don't know so that
that's the problem that goes back to
leadership and we know where that
lack of leadership comes from there was
denial for a long time so i i just
wonder
when
if star player is going to do something
here you know is it going to take a
patrick mahomes or somebody like that
it'll be like man i just saw lebron
james sacrifice a lot in the nba going
to bubble for months because he's
worried about his legacy like is
somebody like that going to step up to
the plate here maybe you know come
december because again whether you think
it's serious or not or you're not scared
of the the virus the simple fact of the
matter is if your team gets it you're in
trouble and therefore that's news and
especially football news and you might
not have star players playing so that's
why we're talking about it that's why
we'll continue to talk about it because
it's the news of our country our world
and it's infiltrated our sport so i just
wonder if that happens here at some
point you know to where some star player
starts to go hey we got a chance to
we're we're a super bowl team here you
know we're we're kansas city we're one
game out of being the one seed we just
need pittsburgh to lose a game i i don't
know i just wonder if the player will
start to
get guys in the locker room to get their
heads around it down the stretch here
for for the big prize at the end of the
season
i'd like to think they already are and
they just aren't publicizing it because
they don't want their opponents to take
it seriously i mean there's a there's a
chess game to this where hey guys come
on look
regardless of what you think of this
virus regardless of whether or not you
think it's real or a hoax here's the
reality it is out there and if you catch
it you get knocked out for a week or two
and if you're in close contact with
someone who has it you get knocked out
of practice for a week so it's there and
it's going to randomly pick us off if
we're not careful so let's be careful
let's do everything we can to avoid it
period regardless of whether or not we
think it's going to make us sick or kill
us it's not we're professional athletes
i mean that's the part of the the
bravado right but still to the extent
that you just look around look around
look at the teams that are dealing with
it look at the ravens this week look at
the raiders against the buccaneers where
they didn't have their offensive line
the entire week look at the ravens last
week or a couple of weeks ago when they
didn't have a bunch of defensive players
the raiders this past past week didn't
have a bunch of defensive players it's
real it's there and i'd like to think
that
for the best teams
when you get in the locker room when
you're talking amongst yourselves i'd
like to think that maybe not though
because you know it's funny when we see
guys on the sidelines during games there
is i think they just believe that
because we're tested every day we're
fine i think that's really yeah we're
tested every day we're fine and they
don't understand that doughnut hole
between
catching it
being exposed having the incubation
period and then you can be negative
negative negative negative until the day
you're positive and you don't find out
until the next day that you were
positive it's really not that
complicated chris if you and i
understand it i'd like to think the guys
in the locker room can understand it you
just have to assume that everyone you
come in contact with has it and act
accordingly and i know it's not easy and
i know it's not convenient and i know
it's not comfortable and i know there's
a lot of voices out there that are being
derisive about it and acting like you're
being unreasonable for being concerned
about it but you know what if you're not
you may not play this week your team may
miss the playoffs because you weren't
available and then it's on you when your
team doesn't make the plows it shouldn't
be that difficult to get that message
across to 32 nfl teams no but i think it
goes back to what you said the bravado
of the nfl football player you know not
really scared of what the virus can do
to them personally i'm in great shape
i'm young i'm not worried about that and
then the testing certainly i think is
adding another layer of you know
relaxation there to just go oh i mean
man it's every day i mean you know it
just it can't go that rampant through
our team or anything like that i mean
even though we've had little examples of
that so no i mean uh i i think
i i don't i doubt there's been those
conversations in the locker room yet i
doubt i bet you there's guys hey go home
be careful do that
but i don't know if i could say that
guys will start to go hey maybe december
we do the hotel thing or you know maybe
the last two weeks going into the
playoffs we do the hotel thing i i doubt
those conversations have come up because
i think guys are also reluctant to get
involved in
people's personal lives in the nfl
locker room at times too it's kind of
like hey you do you i'll do me we'll
meet at football we'll meet together and
we'll work together but then we leave
the locker room and you do you and i'll
do me and that's kind of the culture of
the nfl so that's where it's going to be
interesting to evaluate this whole thing
here down the home stretch
maybe it'll be at the playoffs then when
organically the teams that truly want to
contend won't need to have a home market
bubble that is done in a mandatory
fashion they'll all choose to do it and
look the same issues we're dealing with
now with people traveling and gathering
for the thanksgiving holiday the same
thing's going to happen in a few weeks
when people travel and gather for the
year-end holiday and
i don't know maybe the aftermath of what
happens
this week when the numbers keep
skyrocketing and i don't know we're all
just numb to the numbers the numbers are
through the roof and we all just like no
big deal but no they it is a big deal
maybe what happens next week in the week
after will get people to reconsider
their their plans for the end of the
year but that leads right into the
playoffs chris you can have outbreaks
for playoff teams yes no that that may
not have and uh those they're still
going to play the games
the question is are you going to be at
your best are you going to be as
prepared as you can be are you going to
have as many healthy players who are
able to play the game as you can and
look at the ravens what they're dealing
with this week no
practice yesterday everything was done
virtually the main day of practice on a
short week they weren't even in the
building there's no reason to think
they're going to be in the building
today no at some point they have to get
everybody together and go to pittsburgh
look and again the nfl's attitude is
we're getting this in we're getting this
in we're getting this in we're getting
this in at some time
in this process though the rubbers got
to meet the road right and you either
have to be comfortable bringing everyone
together or you're not yeah no i know
you know that's that's that's uh
this is where i think mike too do you
think teams
look back at the year
and look at the titans and their
situation and go man that that's bs
that's bullcrap they got the games
canceled didn't have to play when their
team was gonna be less at full strength
now we're being forced to to play you
know i'm just bringing it up there
through conversation it kind of popped
into my head there but you know most of
these teams like we've talked about for
the first 25 minutes of the show here
have been forced to play with these
issues tennessee got things juggled
around to where oh hey hey we're all
back healthy again they're at full
strength let's play a game now i just
kind of find that fascinating too
well look it's human nature to complain
about anything that doesn't go your way
john gruden was livid when the nfl
decided not to bump the buccaneers
raiders game that was originally set for
prime time moved back to four o'clock in
the event that they couldn't play it
they didn't want to have an empty hole
in a prime time window and
we argued i remember this vividly play
it on monday play it on tuesday let's go
we want to watch that game we don't want
it tucked into 405 pm eastern when no
one can see it it's tom brady it's john
gruden it's las vegas let's do it right
and the nfl's not no because if we delay
it there's no guarantee we're going to
get it in we're getting the game in that
was when everything shifted so yeah you
could you could be upset if you're the
49ers remember how they were ravaged on
that thursday night a few weeks back
against the packers uh with the ravens
with their defense a few weeks ago with
their offense now with their whole team
now yes there's reason to be salty about
it but the reality is the overriding
objective is and we all need to accept
this
and i know the nfl says that the health
and safety of the players and the
coaches is paramount and i don't have
any reason to doubt that they've done a
good job for the most part of keeping
people from getting the virus but
just under paramount is getting paid and
you don't get paid if you don't play the
games you don't get your money from the
networks and i know it's not linear like
you you get a check every week from nbc
once the game has been played but
there is a broader relationship here and
if you're not delivering the product it
becomes a factor
in whether and to what extent the money
is going to flow in the direction of the
nfl so get all the games in it's never
an issue especially the time when the
nfl's at the bargaining table with all
the networks on the next round of deals
the nfl is obsessed with getting these
games in that's what the mindset became
a few weeks ago and whether or not an
individual team thinks it's fair or
unfair chris to get back to your
original point
keep your guys clean yeah you guys safe
keep your guys virus free and it's on
you if you don't yeah no i i think
that's that's exactly right and that's
where i back at that time we were saying
no you know it should they should
forfeit it or whatever you know for
those reasons but
all right well we are where we are and
we'll see where this goes baltimore wow
to be in this position short week these
players are out of the game
i mean this is uh this is crazy it's the
best team in football last year a team
we thought was going to just kind of
steamroll their way
to the super bowl or at least to the afc
championship game and play patrick
mahomes there was a letdown there and
this year it looked the way it started
and now here we are i mean i just never
would have thought we'd be sitting here
at the end of november going i don't
know if baltimore's going to make the
playoffs this year it's just crazy and
and now i mean it's not looking good
this week as far as this matchup is
concerned with some of these guys
missing
i want to go back to week one because i
thought it would be a challenge for the
ravens to go into what dennis green
called the valley of zero and zero after
being 14 and two losing in the
divisional round you bust your ass all
year long everything goes your way it's
a special season it all collapses on a
three-hour window on a saturday night
now you have to start the climb all over
again when they beat the browns 38-6 to
start the season and i talked to john
harbaugh right after the game from the
locker room i said what have you done to
get your guys to forget about last year
because that that's my assumption that's
the bill belichick way last year doesn't
matter last year's irrelevant last
year's a distraction last year's not
going to do anything to help you this
year harbaugh said
they talk about it they embrace it they
want to meet that standard and exceed it
well that's all well and good until you
get to the point where mathematically
you can't meet that standard and it
doesn't take many losses to get to that
point and now they've doubled their
losses from last year they know that
they're not going to meet the standard
of last year and what did last year get
them it got them a one-and-done playoff
appearance so
they they they they need to on the fly
bury last year chris and just accept
here's where we are
six and four right we're backed against
the wall right and yeah they're quite
possibly gonna be six and five after
tomorrow night and you look at the rest
of the schedule after that they could
get hot they could run the table they go
11 and five right but they just they
they need to get out of this
we're the ravens of 2019 and accept the
fact that they have to become the gritty
dirty raw street fighters who do what
they have to do to win football games
and try to get back to the playoffs the
hard way no i you know i think that's a
great point and you know to what john
harbaugh could say to his own team is go
hey let's look at the team who won a
super bowl last year because that's
basically what they did 2018 magical
year 50 touchdown passes 5 000 yards
chiefs are unstoppable afc championship
game wow we lose a heartbreaker to the
to the new england patriots next year i
mean we were sitting at one point
sitting there going what were they they
were
five and three last year five and three
at one point
and they just said you know what screw
it we're just gonna find a way to win
every game and then some were pretty
some were awesome some were ugly as hell
but it didn't matter and they just kind
of battled through and said this is the
way we are in 2019 you know and and you
know there's something to be learned
about that and maybe the ravens can
learn that and just realize it's not
gonna be as pretty you're gonna be
battled but you're battle tested and
you're gonna have to find other ways to
win and we'll see if they can kind of
you know take it by storm here in the
last month but as it looks right now i'm
i'm very doubtful i don't like the look
of the ravens and especially with the
cove thing and all of that no i'm i'm uh
definitely skeptical about the ravens
chances to make the playoffs with the
position they're in now
chris the comment earlier this week from
lamar jackson was telling he said
everybody wants to see us lose that's
part of the aura of being the team
that's on top but they're not that team
anymore he needs to understand that they
are the team that everyone is just
assuming at this point is going to
continue to fall apart you can use that
to your advantage and you can understand
let's forget about the pride let's
forget about the vanity that comes from
being in the 2019 ravens and we were 14
and 2. none of that matters now all that
matters now is winning week in and week
out and you know how they handle the
test this week even if they lose could
lay the foundation
for what comes on the back end of the
mini buy because they fought through it
and they proved a lot to themselves
they're taking the virus seriously now
finally maybe they're choosing to set up
a voluntary bubbles they don't have to
deal with it again there's a way through
this mess to find a positive
no there definitely is i mean if you win
a game like this this week or even keep
it close and there's things to take away
from it schematically physically hey we
did this we did that it could be one of
those things that kind of brings the
team together and you know gives them
one more you know jack of energy to make
a push here down the stretch it's very
possible it doesn't take much in the nfl
to just start going hey wait we are
pretty good and hey you know wait why
are we making it so complicated you know
one win one positive moment can kind of
change a team's mindset after a few
weeks of like what the hell is going on
with us we'll see if they can turn the
tide this week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports